I wasn't sure what I could say to you I
wanted to say the right thing and I was
really nervous that I I wouldn't or that
it would get picked apart and I realized
the only wrong thing to say is to say
nothing
Megan Markel is speaking out for the
first time since the death of George
Floyd George Floyd's life mattered and
Brianna Taylor's life mattered and
falando Castillo's life mattered and
Tamir Rice's life mattered and so did so
many other people whose names we know
and whose names we do not know people
all across the world have been publicly
protesting against police brutality
after Floyd died at the age of 46 when a
police officer pressed his knee into his
neck for more than eight minutes now in
a new message to the graduating class of
Immaculate Heart High School her alma
mater the 38 year old Duchess of Sussex
addressed the state of the country so
the first thing I want to say to you is
that I'm sorry I am so sorry that you
have to grow up in a world where this is
still present Markel reflected on a
piece of advice that her high school
teacher gave her when she was a
sophomore always remember to put others
needs before your own fears now he's
stuck with me through my entire life and
I've thought about it more in the last
week than ever before Markel who is
biracial also recalled the 1992 Los
Angeles Riots which she experienced when
she was 10 years old I remember rushing
back home and on that drive home seeing
ash fall from the sky and smelling the
smoke and seeing the smoke billow out of
buildings and seeing people run out of
buildings carrying bags and looting and
those memories don't go away and I can't
imagine that it 17 or 18 years old which
is how old you are now that you would
have to have a different version of that
same type of experience the Duchess
urged her fellow alumni to be examples
in the community
and in the world you are going to lead
with love you are going to lead with
compassion you are going to use your
voice you were going to use your voice
in a stronger way than you've ever been
able to because most of you are 18 or
you're going to turn 18 so you're going
to vote and she wrapped her message up
with a call to action you are going to
have empathy for those who don't see the
world through the same lens that you do
because with this diverse and vibrant
and open mind and as I know the
teachings and immaculate heart are I
know you know that black lives matter so
I am already excited for what you are
going to do in the world you are
equipped you are ready we need you and
you are prepared
Markel and her husband Prince Harry
stepped down from their roles as senior
Royals on March 31st and relocated to LA
with their one-year-old son Archie where
they'd been quarantine ndu to the corona
virus pandemic but before Markel
delivered her message to the all-girls
Catholic school she was already
inspiring some of the students there who
started the group students for Floyd
what are you hoping to achieve through
this organization what are your goals
well my goals right now are obviously
just going to protest and showing that
we can get a large group of kids
together to take action and make
initiative and then we're also leading a
bunch of cleanups to kind of help with
the aftermath of the protest cleaning up
graffiti helping out shops all that
stuff ET spoke with a 17 year old
founder of the initiative who said
Markel has had a huge impact on her
i've been so inspired by her and also
just my school community as well because
everything that she speaks about and
stands for i think was really instilled
in her at our school
[Music]